OBSTRUCTION OF JUSTICE.
COULD BE UP FOR A FULL HOUSE
VOTE BY NEXT WEEK.
HERE'S THE PRESIDENT.
>> THE FACTS ON SHIFTY SCHIFF.
THIS HONEST GUY.
MIX UP MY STATEMENTS
DISHONEST GUY, MAKES UP MY
STATEMENTS.
WE SAID, SAY IT, YOU CROOKED SAY
IT.
>> REMEMBER, BRIBERY, THIS COME
OF THAT.
WHERE ARE THEY?
THEY SAID THESE TWO THINGS, NOT
EVEN A CRIME!
THIS IS THE LIGHTEST, WEAKEST
IMPEACHMENT!
THIS IS IMPEACHMENT LITE.
>> Juan: ANOTHER DEMOCRAT SAYS
THE PRESIDENT COULD BE IMPEACHED
AGAIN IF THE CURRENT EFFORT
FAILS.
>> EVEN THOUGH WE ARE IMPEACHING
HIM NOW, THERE IS STILL A NUMBER
OF COURT CASES, A TON OF
INFORMATION THAT COULD COME
FORWARD.
FOR EXAMPLE, WE CAN GET HIS BANK
RECORDS AND FIND OUT THAT HE IS
OWNED 100% BY THE RUSSIANS.
>> Juan: DANA, THE HOUSE
IMPEACHMENT COMMITTEE WILL BEGIN
TONIGHT, TAKING A LOOK AT THE
ARTICLES OF IMPEACHMENT.
THEY COULD RESUME AGAIN TOMORROW
MORNING.
WHAT IS IT, WHAT HAPPENS THERE?
>> Dana: IT'S GOING TO BE
PRETTY BORING.
A MARKUP OF THE HEARING IS A
PRETTY BORING -- LIKE WE KEEP
SAYING, WE KNOW THE OUTCOME.
WE SKIP AHEAD, WE KNOW HOW THIS
IS GOING TO END.
WE KNOW THE TWIST AND TURNS AND
HOW LONG THE SENATE TRIAL WILL
BE, BUT WE KNOW WHAT IT'LL LOOK
LIKE.
BUT IT FEELS LIKE THAT WE ARE
THE ROAD RUNNER AND WE ARE
WATCHING WILE E. COYOTE JUST
WALK RIGHT OFF THE CLIFF.
SORRY, WOW.
SPLAT.
WHAT YOU ARE SEEING IN TERMS OF
THE POLLS.
THE REPUBLICANS HAVEN'T CHANGED
MINDS EITHER, RIGHT?
IS COMPLETELY STATIC IN THE LAST
FEW MONTHS.
IN FACT, THE LAST THREE YEARS
INSTEAD OF SOME OF THE
BATTLEGROUND STATES WHERE THE
PRESIDENT STARTS TO DO A LITTLE
BETTER.
MAYBE DEMOCRATS THINK THEY CAN
GET THIS DONE AND MAKE UP FOR
LOST TIME.
BUT I DON'T KNOW WHAT THEY ARE
DOING.
>> Juan: JESSE, YOU'RE A A
MASTER OF RHETORIC.
>> Dana: [LAUGHS]
>> Juan: WHY DID YOU SAY THAT?
>> Dana: I THINK IT'S FUNNY
WHEN YOU GIVE THEM A LITTLE BIT
OF A BOOST.
SPEAK TO HIS MOM TEXT, I JUST
TRY TO GIVE ENCOURAGEMENT LIKE A
MOTHER.
>> Greg: YOU ARE A MOTHER!
[LAUGHTER]
>> Juan: ANYWAY, IMPEACHMENT
LITE.
SLEEPY JOE, POCAHONTAS --
>> Dana: MINI MIKE.
>> Jesse: YOU GUYS DON'T HAVE
ANYONE PLAYING A TUNE AT ALL.
IT'S LIKE A RECORD SCRATCH.
IMPEACHMENT LITE IS A GREAT WAY
TO DESCRIBE IT.
YOU NOTICE THIS DOESN'T SEEM
LIKE A REAL IMPEACHMENT?
I MEAN, IT'S LIKE A PRESEASON
GAME.
YOU ARE WATCHING -- BUT IT
DOESN'T REALLY COUNT.
DOESN'T GO ANYWHERE, IT'S JUST
ON THE RECORD.
NONE OF THE GOOD PLAYERS ARE IN.
>> Greg: IT'S LIKE WHEN YOU GO
TO UNIVERSAL STUDIOS AND THEY DO
THE MOVIE, LIKE THEY DO
"GHOSTBUSTERS" BUT IT'S ALL THE
BAD SUMMER STOCK ACTORS.
>> Jesse: THESE AREN'T SERIOUS
ARTICLES, IT'S BEING LED BY
SCHIFF.
A YEAR AGO, SCHIFF SAID THE
DOSSIER HAD NOTHING TO DO WITH
THE FISA WARRANTS.
IT HAD EVERYTHING TO DO WITH IT
AND WE ARE SUPPOSED TO GO ALONG
WITH THIS GUY AND BELIEVE
EVERYTHING HE SAID ABOUT THE
WHISTLE-BLOWER, UKRAINE AND ALL
OVER AGAIN?
IT'S ENOUGH, ONE.
I DON'T HAVE ANYTHING ELSE TO
SAY ABOUT IT.
>> Greg: I DON'T BELIEVE THAT.
>> Jesse: I'M THE MASTER OF
RHETORIC!
>> Juan: FROM MY PERSPECTIVE,
HE ENGAGED IN THIS RHETORIC AND
IT MADE
EVERY AND THEY JUST SAY, YOU
KNOW WHAT, LET'S MOVE ON.
THERE IS A CONSPIRACY ABOUT
FISA.
IT SEEMS TO ME, WOW, HOW DO
PEOPLE CLOSE THEIR EYES?
>> Greg: I DON'T KNOW WHAT
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT.
IT'S RIGHT.
IT'S ALL FALLING APART.
IMPEACHMENT IS HELPING THEM IN
BATTLEGROUND STATES.
THERE IS ALWAYS AN
OVERCORRECTION WHEN THERE IS
OVERREACH.
I THINK THAT'S WHY THEY'VE GOT
TO KEEP TRYING TO IMPEACH HIM,
JUST TRY TO COME UP WITH ANOTHER
CRIME AND FILL IN THE BLANKS
LIKE IT'S A COLORING BOOK
BECAUSE IT HELPS THEM BECAUSE
PEOPLE ARE GOING LIKE, THIS IS A
BUNCH OF B.S.
WHAT A WASTE OF TIME.
>> Jesse: THEY HAVE A NEW
POLL, JUAN.
QUINNIPIAC POLL.
DO YOU WANT TO SHOW THE
AUDIENCE?
I'LL TAKE IT FROM HERE.
NATIONAL POLL, NO IMPEACHMENT
GIVEN THE REMOVAL.
>> Greg: WE THOUGHT YOU WERE
DONE TALKING ABOUT IT!
>> Juan: TOTALLY A MASTER OF
RHETORIC, A MASTER OF HOSTING.
LARGELY STATIC.
BEFORE, YOU ARE RIGHT.
>> Greg: HE'S GOING TO WIN IN
A LANDSIDE IF YOU KEEP SAYING
THIS, JUAN.
>> Dana: CHANGING THE MINDS OF
DEMOCRATS AND CONGRESSIONAL
DISTRICTS THAT TRUMP WON.
DEMOCRATS ARE NOT WORRIED ABOUT
HURTING FOR IMPEACHMENT.
I ALSO SAW TODAY THAT THERE MAY
BE DEMOCRAT SENATORS WHO ARE
THINKING ABOUT VOTING AGAINST
IMPEACHMENT.
>> Katie: THERE WILL BE.
>> Dana: THIS IS A LOSE-LOSE
FOR DEMOCRATS.
>> Katie: SCHUMER'S JOB IS TRY
TO WIN BACK THE MAJORITY.
HOUSE IMPEACHMENT GOING TO GO
OVER THERE?
>> Juan: I HEARD FROM CHARLES
SCHUMER TODAY ON IT.
MR. SCHUMER SAID THAT THIS IS A
STRONG CASE FOR CONVICTION AND,
I NOTE, THAT DEMOCRATS, THE
DEMOCRATIC BASE, AS WE'VE HEARD
JUST NOW AND YOU SAW THE POLL
THAT THE MASTER HOST PUT UP,
THAT IN FACT THE DEMOCRATS
'SUPPORT HAS NOT WANED.
IT IS STILL THERE.
>> Greg: YOU DO SENSE A
FEELING OF THE CHARLIE BROWN
TRYING TO KICK THE BALL BECAUSE
YOU CAN SEE IT ON TWITTER.
THE HOPES AREN'T AS HIGH AS THEY
USED TO BE.
THEY ARE JUST, LIKE, MAYBE THIS
WILL COME.
BUT THEY KNOW THEY'VE BEEN
SCREWED.
KATE
: DELMA >> Katie: THE FISA STUFF
: DELMA >> Katie: THE FISA STUFA
: DELMA >> Katie: THE FISA STUFD
SAYING THAT PRESIDENT TRUMP IS
SAYING ABOUT ALL THIS STUFF BUT
ADAM SCHIFF HAS FAR LESS CREDIT
ABILITY WHEN IT COMES TO THIS
WITH THAN PRESIDENT TRUMP.
>> Juan: IF THE IG REPORT HAS
BEEN GOOD NEWS FOR TRUMP,
IMAGINE.
"TIME" MAGAZINE NAMED THEIR
PERSON OF THE YEAR -- NO, IT'S
NOT ME.
IT'S NOT JESSE.
ALTHOUGH DANA GOT IT RIGHT.
WE WILL TELL YOU WHO IT IS NEXT
ON "THE FIVE."